- This has been an exciting thing for me,
to start a new show, so I'm super excited.
I'm wearing my onesie.
(knocking at door)
(crowd applauding)
It's like, it feels like a--
- Kelly?
Kelly?
- Oh, hey, what's up, Ellen?
(crowd cheering)
What?
You guys!
What's up?!
What're you doing here?
- Thank you, thank you so much.
I just wanted to say,
I knew you were starting
today and I was just, not,
I wasn't in the neighborhood.
I came here just to say
congratulations, good luck,
and I want you to have
a really great show.
(applauding)
- Thank you, Ellen!
That was so nice!
(crowd cheering)
What?
Ellen, what's wrong?
- I'm sorry.
- What's wrong?
(crowd cheering)
- I'm so sorry.
- What's wrong?
I'm so honored!
- Is that a chair?
- Yes, it is now.
(laughing)
- I was looking for the exit
and they said it was that way
and I'm so, I'm interrupting
your show and I'm so sorry.
- No, wait, you're here, they love you,
I love you, just stay a little!
(crowd cheering)
Just stay a little longer!
- Actually, I'm so glad you said that.
I actually brought a gift.
So for my first show, Jennifer
Aniston, she's a friend.
(laughing)
- Drop.
- She,
brought me a gift for my first show
and it was good luck 'cause
I'm on for 17 seasons
and I want the same for you.
- Okay 17 seasons?!
(clapping)
What?
- So she brought me a welcome
mat and it was good luck
and I wanted to bring you
something for your set
so that you had good luck.
- Okay, I want it, what is it?
What is it?
- Okay.
- What is it?
(crowd applauding)
I got a gift from Ellen.
(laughing)
First of all, your childlike hands
are my favorite, it's the best!
- Those are my hands.
- They're childlike hands!
- How dare you!
(laughing)
- This is, like, amazing.
- How dare you!
- This is going in my office.
- No, no, no!
It's supposed to be on the set.
- Okay, I'll do that.
Don't you threaten me
with a good time, ma'am.
All right, I'm gonna
find the perfect spot,
maybe just like on the brick
wall, maybe we do that.
- What're we all talking about?
I wanna be a part of the conversation.
- Okay, well, we were
talking about Instagrannies,
have you ever heard of that?
- I just recently did when I was backstage
waiting to come back out.
(laughing)
- Well, wait, where's Baddie?
There's Baddie!
Hey, Baddie, what's up?
(crowd applauding)
So this is @baddiewinkle, y'all.
She's from Kentucky and has
nearly four million viewers.
(crowd applauding)
Okay, wait, so Baddie,
your real name is Helen,
so do you like to go by Helen or Baddie?
- Well, I like to be called Baddie
because everybody mostly knows me.
- [Kelly] I love your accent.
- By Baddie and I am a baddie bitch.
(laughing)
I'm also a rebel, always been a rebel.
Always will be a rebel.
- Yeah, you said, bitch
in daytime, you're good.
(laughing)
All right, so how did you
get started on Instagram?
I'm curious 'cause my
mom's not on Instagram.
- Okay, I took one little picture.
So it went viral in a week.
- Aw, that's cute, well, how
do you keep staying so young?
Is it staying on Instagram,
is that your secret?
- Well, I get on Instagram
almost every single day.
It takes time.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] Do you have any
advice for other grannies
out there wanting to nail it on Instagram?
- [Baddie] The lighting and the angles
is very important.
- Lighting is key.
- I had to learn that.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- If they wanna be on
Instagram, just get on there,
do your thing and be yourself.
- Oh my God, I love you.
All right, well thank you so much!
- Before I go, I wanted to ask you,
because I brought you a gift,
if you had a gift for your audience,
'cause they like gifts.
- Well, I don't know if you heard, Ellen,
but I did give a gift of song, so.
(crowd cheering)
We're a first season here, so
we have a little tiny budget.
- Oh, you have a budget.
Okay.
- A little one.
- Well, I brought
something for the audience
'cause I know, so.
(audience cheering)
- Let's do this, let's do this!
- I don't wanna stand here,
can we bring an easel out or something?
- Let's bring an easel, okay.
Well, I can get an easel.
- You have a budget for an easel?
- I have a budget for an easel.
(laughing)
- All right, let's put this over there.
- All right, let's put it, here we go.
(soft music)
All right, I just want
this to stay behind me
the whole show, that would be amazing.
- This stays there the whole season.
- The whole, she said, I
said show, she said season!
Seriously, do you have any advice for me?
Come on.
- Look at how I said,
have a seat.
- I know!
(laughing)
You're used to it.
- Like it's my show.
- And look how like I was like, yes ma'am.
I was like, I'm used to that too, so.
- So you're enjoying it?
- I am, I am!
- Yeah?
You're not bored with it yet?
- No, no, but I love it.
- It's a fun thing, 'cause
you have the proximity
of the people right here,
and they get the energy
and they get to see you so close up.
- I know, I had to move 'em forward
because even on tour I
don't like when the audience
is so far, I like to play off of them.
- Right, I agree.
- You're probably like that,
you're a comedian obviously.
- Yes, I like people close up,
but I like how lit they are,
'cause they're part of the show.
It's not like it's you and them.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, it's good.
- We want everyone to look 20.
(laughing)
- So everyone's lit with
little things under them.
- We have little Beyonce
lights for everyone.
- [Ellen] That's so nice of you.
- No, but obviously
you said you had a gift
so I'm just gonna bring it up again
'cause I'm excited for them.
(audience laughing)
I'm like, I'm so glad you're
here, where's the gifts?
I'm just kidding.
- No, people like gifts.
- They do.
- You have a gift and now I wanted
to give something to the audience.
- That's very kind.
- This is exciting, I
think you're gonna like it.
Who likes kittens?
(laughing)
- I'm allergic but it's great.
- All right, no, I'm just
curious, it was just a question.
(laughing)
It has nothing to do with the gift.
- I just got terrified!
- I just love kittens.
All right, who likes plants?
- I love plants.
(audience cheering)
I love gardening and trees.
- Like ficus plants, like house plants?
Ferns, ivy...
- Succulents!
- Succulents are so easy to take care of.
- [Kelly] You don't really have to.
- Don't have to do anything.
- It's a cold person's plant.
(laughing)
- It's someone who doesn't really
have to have responsibility at all.
All right, so.
(crowd laughing)
- No succulents either, no plants?
- No plants, no.
- No plants, okay, okay.
- No, I'm just playing
around, wasting time.
- [Kelly] I love it, I love it.
- And I can't.
- You can waste
my time the whole show!
- No, no, no, I can't.
I have to actually get back to my show.
I came over here to see
you to give you this
but I have to now do my show as well.
But so the gift is, you all
know that for I don't know,
like five years now, maybe
more, we've been in business
with TCL Roku and they have the best TVs
and so everyone here needs to
have a 65-inch TCL Roku TV.
(crowd cheering)
- That's so good!
- You should show 'em
what the box looks like.
- Okay, so this is actually great.
Ellen pointed out that we
really wanted y'all to know
what the box looks like
that it came in as well.
I don't know why we didn't just bring out
the really fancy nice TVs.
- It's important to see
what the box looks like.
- And this is what it's gonna
look like on your doorstep.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much!
- Have fun!
- Thank you!
- Kelly Clarkson, everybody!